Look at this one little
bitty itty Lego piece.
Did someone painstakingly put each
of these little circles on top, or
take a huge piece of plastic and
chisel it down to this?
Did someone carefully mix the colors
together to create just this right
shade of green?
Now think about asking
these same questions for
every single one of these pieces.
There's no way that each
piece was made by hand.
They used a mold or template.
Using a mold, you can make thousands
of pieces incredibly quickly.
Depending on which mold you use,
you've already determined the size and
shape of the pieces.
One thing that the mold can't
decide though is color.
It's dynamic and is chosen near the end.
So a template gives you a starting point
with a default structure and content.
But just like color,
you might need to provide specific
information before it's usable.